good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and ASCP were going to be looking
at today is SCP 1207 object class safe
special containment procedures SCP 1207
is to be wrapped in opaque cloth and
contained within a standard inanimate
objects locker in accordance with
standard protocol for direct exposure
line-of-sight Cognito hazards SCP 1207
is to be kept under constant real-time
video surveillance whenever it is
removed from its locker for any purpose
maintenance analysis experimentation etc
direct exposure to SCP 1207 is to be
minimized maximum cumulative direct
exposure for individual personnel is not
to exceed two hours within a 30-day
period or 24 hours within an individual
lifetime personnel whose cumulative
direct exposure to SCP 1207 exceeds 2
hours within a 30-day period are to be
immediately placed on psychological
leave until such time as they have been
judged free of the symptoms of body
dysmorphic disorder and are not to
resume active duty until they have
successfully undergone retraining in
data entry and proofreading description
SCP 1207 is a mere approximately 1 meter
by 1/2 meter in science in a white
wooden frame painted with pink and red
hearts using the Kin scale method of
mirror type object evaluation foundation
scientists have established it as a
minor level psychological threat the
previous paragraph was stricken from the
document SCP 1207 is a metal sign
approximately 1 meter by 1/2 meter in
size painted white with embossed letters
reading this is a mirror you are a typo
it is a direct exposure Cognito hazard
which manifests three distinct anomalous
effects upon subjects within line of
sight
the first effect which is the most
obvious is that any sighted the words
person and mammal have been stricken
from the document vertebrate directly
exposed to SCP 1207 will perceive it as
being a mirror even if they are aware of
its true nature test subjects not
capable of mirror recognition will
perform territorial threat displays
against SCP 1207 human subjects
uniformly described the mirrors being
contained within a white wooden frame
with pink and red hearts however more
detailed descriptions vary from subject
to subject blindfolded subjects report
that SCP 1207 feels smooth and glassy
with wood around the edges conversely
blind subjects report that SCP 1207
feels metallic and bumpy it is to be
emphasized that despite perceptions and
reactions of affected subjects SCP 1207
does not actually function as a mirror
the second anomalous effect is that
subjects exposed to SCP 1207 will
rapidly develop symptoms of body
dysmorphic disorder as they examine
their reflections human subjects will
voice a variety of complaints about
their physical appearance ranging from
I'm the wrong height to my tattoo is
crooked and always ending with I'm not
cool yet non-human subjects capable of
mirror recognition will perform
compulsive grooming as cumulative
exposure time to SCP 1207 increases
subjects will begin to modify their
appearances in attempts to correct
themselves
typically by application of cosmetics
subjects without access to cosmetics
will engage in self-mutilation such
subjects when shown actual mirrors will
express satisfaction with their
modifications
however when re exposed to SCP 1207
subjects will again find fault with
their appearance
the third anomalous effect is that
subjects exposed to SCP 1207 will
gradually develop symptoms of dyslexia
losing their ability to spell and to
notice spelling errors this effect is
limited to subjects familiar with the
English language and always begins with
the subject consistently misspelling the
word mirror Mir RoR as Mir Oh are the
induced dyslexia is temporary
however the factors determining the rate
at which individual subjects recover
have not yet been determined SCP 1207
was discovered in an abandoned storage
unit facility in which had been in use
as a workspace by members of the group
of interest currently identified as are
we cool yet it is theorized that SCP
1207 was to form the basis of an
unfinished installation notes left by
the artist indicate that the completed
installation was a rumination on the
essence of how the ways we see ourselves
shape what we are ok this was a short
lecture today so you're welcome but that
about does it for today thank you all
for listening and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Pierce M Hamlin Muslim Mookie slump
God dr. day John Oh quarter
captain Gorge fluffy sky key mana moon a
my archive curator neck tie verbal Kody
tench cheese whip
I'm Depp's McGee thank you all so much
for your support
I really appreciate it if you would like
a special thank you at the end of each
of my videos on some other cool stuff as
well as at patreon.com forward slash the
vulcan thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]